you have a beautiful voice so is it
harder to convincingly sing flat or to
sing well well I kind of had to do both
I had to kind of learn these very
difficult areas which was so much fun
and then I had to ruin them so I had to
know where the right note was in order
to just skim it we shot it live which I
had not anticipated you know in Mamma
Mia we we did a pre record and on set we
would sing along with that stephen
frears our great director to just do it
live so we did it one of the things I've
done so much authenticity I think to
your performance is the fact that you
actually play piano yeah so she's she's
singing it live and in order for that to
work you had to have a piano player
accompanying her life because it was
going to change every time she's like a
plane sort of going down and hitting the
tops of trees and you have to sort of
keep up with her you have to kind of
know it well in order to to undo it so
you play Sinclair bayfield Florence's
husband and I'm curious what was your
read on this guy because he's incredibly
devoted to her but he lives in a
separate apartment with a woman that he
doesn't want Florence to know about it
seemed like he loved making her happy do
you think it made him happy yes I do
you're right that it's a very odd
domestic arrangement that they have and
it's not classical and this everyone can
still be happy and it can still be
plenty of love and as my character says
in his film once at some point he says
ours was a very happy world and I think
that is true this city and so many
people had had a fascination with her
and they loved I mean she called out
Carnegie Hall yeah in in a record amount
of time and what do you think people
loved so much about her well the train
wreck thank you I think word spread and
this was her first public concert and
she had sold Sinatra who played the
night before that all that's really true
she's wild yeah let's get started
you